hannah is lovely to see you here at the
London Film on comic-con how you
enjoying it today
absolutely it's lovely to be here let me
to see you now of course I'm sure lots
of your friends are asking about
primeval today because you had a quarry
carriage and that very strong winner
independent Abbey what was it you
enjoyed about playing her oh I just
loved her through and through it's
really really great to kind of be
involved one in a show that was yeah I
was sort of involved with the start of
it and something new and something fresh
and then characterized you know Abbey
was kind of developed really I mean she
was always going to be quite strong but
you know as these things go once once
you've the chemistry starts with certain
characters and they get a feel for how
you're doing it then it kind of goes
from there and then yeah I miss Abbey
yeah so many people actually come on
today and sort of said Paul is it gonna
be a series six and it's like well no
plans but yeah if you'd like to come
back if there was it yeah we'll do it
let's go I yeah of course I'm massively
proud and fond of the show but whether
that's movi it's the right thing to come
back or not I don't know because we kind
of finished on series 5 if we did sort
of wrap it up quite nicely you know the
end of series 3 we very much needed to
come back because it was so much so much
on a cliffhanger that it was almost
frustrating for fans and stuff like that
so but I think if they did anything then
maybe like an hour special or something
would work quite nicely cuz it's been so
so long now
so it's so we'll see but yet like I said
nope no plans what are you looking over
those five series which are the kind of
favorite story lines or moments that you
have oh god there's so many but yeah
really fond of the first series and the
second series and then the thing that
makes me really laugh is this the fight
that Abby had with Caroline I loop that
back up on YouTube the other day and my
true of my friend I was just yeah we
were giggling about it together it's
just it's just yeah it's kind of really
bad but really good at the same I love
those moments I now when you can look
back and you think oh oh yeah awesome I
know I know and just like yeah it kind
of cringy as well but yeah kind of good
if you were going to kind of jump
through an anomaly which time or place
would you like to go so you go anywhere
and I've said it before but I would like
to go back to the 60s just to yeah just
to that time period
everything's here and the music and the
festivals and yeah I just like to see
London at that time yes soak up the
flavor and the fine and what can we look
forward to next from you I don't know I
just come off a film actually that is
quite exciting it's a British
independent movie called the coop I'll
repeat that not the boob because
somebody I think his name is Paul
thought I was saying boob earlier I was
like no it's the GUP so that should be
coming out next year what's lovely is
that it's we filmed actually in Norfolk
which is going from it sets against a
lot of it was shot there's a racetrack
in swap em dirty sort of stock car race
track so a lot of it is set against
there and it's about love and family
loyalties and I'd be really interested
to see it come together it's all been
put together at the minute and really
excited about that
my deal next roles ideal next directors
are actors to work with I want to do
next I do would like to do some TV I
wouldn't mind doing another independent
I've never done the independent before
and that was really on my wish list to
do and I had a lovely time doing so
lovely bunch of people and everything
like that so but anything that I can get
my teeth into and it feels different
from something that I've done before we
look forward to that thanks so much for
talking to Tana you very much
you